il serait quelques 200000 en France et à
l'encontre des idées reçues les élèves à
haut potentiel intellectuel ne sont pas
toujours en réussite à l'école
aujourd'hui encore leur scolarité
s'avère parfois douloureuse et chaotique
c'est le principal constat livré par ce
documentaire La dur vie des surdoués
réalisé par celui qui est maintenant
avec nous sur ce plateau Alexandre
Bitoun bienvenue à vous vous êtes
réalisateur documentariste avec
notamment un film consacré à Guillaume
de pardieu qui a d'ailleurs été salué
hein par la profession et tout le monde
l'a compris après ce film vous êtes
vous-même une personne à haut potentiel
intellectuel ce qui vous a valu un très
douloureux souvenir de votre scolarité
et vous a donné envie on l'a vu quelques
années plus tard avec ce film de voir si
les choses avaient positivement évolué
concernant vos semblables aujourd'hui on
va bien sûr revenir sur votre film dans
un instant Ariel had est également avec
nous pour parler de cette scolarité des
élèves à haut potentiel intellectuel
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes psychologue
spécialiste des enfants présentant des
cautions intellectuelles élevées des
enfants des adolescents que vous avez
toujours préféré appeler doué d'ailleurs
plutôt que surdoué on vous doit entre
autres psychologie des enfants très
doués un ouvrage à se procurer aux
éditions ody Jacob et puis enfin avec
nous Marie-Pierre rixin bienvenue euh
vous êtes député renaissance de lesson
ancienne présidente de la la délégation
au droits des femmes et à l'égalité des
chances entre les hommes et les femmes
de l'Assemblée nationale et en novembre
2018 vous avait été la corapporteuse
d'une mission parlementaire intitulée je
cite précocité et trouble associé quelle
prise en charge à l'école point
d'interrogation c'est effectivement le
notre sujet du jour ce rapport vous
l'avez remis en janvier 2019 au ministre
de l'Éducation de l'époque autrement dit
Jean-Michel Blanquer vous aviez un
regard totalement vierge par rapport à
ce problème au moment de réaliser ce
rapport ou pas non puisque je suis
moi-même maman d'un enfant à haut
potentiel qui a aujourd'hui 14 ans qui
donc devait en avoir 10 à l'époque et
donc non je n'avais pas ce regard
totalement vierge je l'assume
parfaitement mais en revanche ma
corapporteur Frédéric meunier ma
collègue donc députée avec laquelle j'ai
fait ce rapport n'était pas du tout
concerné j'ai envie de dire directement
par ce sujet et donc notre notre rapport
est le fruit de ce double regard et je
crois que c'est ce qui a permis de
nourrir à la fois l'attention que que
nous avons porté auprès du ministre sur
sur ce sujet alors qui dit rapport dit
préconisation on en reparlera dans dans
un instant votre fils 14 ans nous
dites-vous il est en quelle classe
aujourd'hui il est en seconde ouais une
classe charnière he on l'a bien compris
dans ce documentaire peut-être qu'on en
reparlera tout à l'heure si vous voulez
si je devais retourner à l'école je MOS
poserit de toutes mes forces c'est avec
cette phrase que vous commencez votre
film est-ce que vous diriez la même
chose après avoir réaliser ce
documentaire après avoir vu comment se
passent les choses notamment dans
desétablissements comme George brassins
qui est beaucoup mieux en avant dans ce
dans ce film et il est mis il a été mis
en place un dispositif spécifique pour
ses élèves à haut potentiel intellectuel
alors tout d'abord si j'ai souhaité
réaliser ce film c'était aussi dans une
démarche justement de faire part de mes
des difficultés que j'ai pu avoir à
l'école qui je pense n'était pas
forcément à mettre sur le compte de mon
potentiel je pense que j'ai développé
certaines difficultés qui n'ont pas
forcément de rapport avec cette
particularité enfin parle souvent de
particularités quand on parle de de haut
potentiel vous tes peties
particularité certains disent différence
mais c'est pas est-ce que c'est pas ça à
la base qui qui qui pose un problème
cette différence lorsqu'on est jeune
lorsqu'on a entre 6 et 16 ans ce
sentiment d'être d'avoir une
particularité une différence est-ce que
c'est pas là le début du problème pour
un pour un jeune alors disons que cette
différence comme vous l'appelez elle a
été identifiée à l'âge de 13 ans et à la
base c'était justement pour déceler mes
difficultés scolaires et donc finalement
le le test a révélé que j'étais à haut
potentiel mais 135 au test de caucion
intellectuel reconnu partout dans le
monde hein selon des normes reconnu euh
partout dans le monde hein c'était le
score obtenu lors de de votre test euh
il vous a posé problème ce ce test c'est
pas que ça m'a posé problème c'est que
disons que ça m'a interpellé puisque
j'étais souvent montré comme un enfant
en difficulté et pas seulement à l'école
mais aussi par mon entourage même si
disons enfin mes parents ont toujours eu
confiance en moi mais disons que je
voilà je j'été pointé du Doig comme
quelqu'un qui avait avvez des
difficultés finalement on vous explique
que vous avez un un potentiel donc c'est
là où euh vous voyez il y a et puis il y
a l'incompréhension aussi des camarades
parce que souvent on met euh enfin les
les notes pour quand on quand on est
scolarisé euh les camarades assimilent
souvent les notes au reflet de
l'intelligence et donc c'est vrai que
j'avais une image de moi-même qui était
très
détériorée ce genre de témoignages
j'imagine que vous les avez quasiment
tous les jours dans votre cabinet avec
des enfants accompagnés souvent de de
parents qui s'interrogent beaucoup euh
les témoignages que nous avons vu dans
ce film que vous avez recueilli aussi ça
ne doit pas vous étonner non le drame
d'Alexandre si je pe dire c'est que il a
été détecté tard alors que quand on voit
un enfant qui a 6 ans 7 ans et que on
identifie je dis toujours qu'un enfant a
besoin de se sentir compris on a besoin
de lui apporter une grille de lecture
homogène quelque chose où il se
reconnaît où les parents connaissent
mais c'est une grille lecture pourquoi
il réagit comme ça et mais quand il est
jeune c'est parfait mais à 13 ans il y a
des quantités de systèmes de défense des
protections qui ont été mis en place il
a il s'est construit une armure et qui
l'enferme et donc 13 ans malheureusement
c'est tard c'est vraiment une question
de chance donc règle numéro 1 précocité
pour identifier un éventuel haut
potentiel oui il faut ifier il faut
absolument faire un test sinon une
impression générale c'est non d'abord ça
donne les points forts les points
faibles donc il faut un test et puis la
façon don les enfants réagissent le le
drame des enfants doués c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas le sens de l'effort et si la
scolarité est trop facile ils nont pas
du tout le sens de l'effort et après ils
s'effondre parce qu'ils ne savent pas
travailler il faut absolument faire un
test nous dites-vous mais si j'ai bien
compris euh il s'agit pas uniquement de
faire un test d'avoir les résultats
d'abord un test ça coûte relativement
cher j'ai vu des chiffres de l'ordre de
400 € pour obtenir un test aujourd'hui
il y a même un véritable
business de ces test aujourd'hui en
ligne dramaque il faut aussi un
accompagnement psychologique pour
l'enfant et et et les parents à la suite
de ce test or souvent ce n'est pas le
casoui mais si vous avez la grille de
lecture si vous savez comprendre
pourquoi il réagit comme ça c'est déjà
beaucoup plus facile d'accompagner on n
pas besoin forcément de thérapie pour un
enfant doué on peut le voir de temps en
temps mais il y a pas besoin de le
suivre vraiment il n'est pas malade il y
a pas je trouve aussi que différence
n'est pas exactement il est il va plus
vite il comprend plus vite il comprend
plus de choses il a un champ d'intérêt
plus large c'est tout un petit peu plus
c'est pas une différence vraiment
fondamentale c'est en mieux c'est
quelque chose de plus mais alors là
effectivement si le reste les autres
enfants ne sont pas comme ça ça ne va
pas du tout il va beaucoup plus vite il
court enfin quand s marche c'est comme
si' il courait par rapport aux autres
alors on va allier à la fois le le
constat fait dans le cadre de votre
mission parlementaire le profil
finalement hein de de des élèves et des
jeunes dont on parle aujourd'hui puis
petite le cas plus personnel qui
concerne votre fils
euh qu'est-ce qui distingue ses enfants
qu'est-ce qui peut provoquer un un
mal-être durant la scolarité de de ces
enfants pour l'essentiel alors moi je
suis entourée de l'un d'entre eux à la
maison et de beaucoup d'entre eux parce
que forcément mon mon mon enfant a été
également scolarisé avec certains
d'entre eux pas d'ailleurs
nécessairement dans une classe dédiée
aux enfants à au potentiel et d'ailleurs
on dit très clairement enfin moi c'est
ma position et Frédéric Meier le le
partager je crois nous l'avons dit dans
le rapport je ne crois pas du touté
Meier vous citez son nom c'est celle la
co rapporteur qui est une députéum et
nous étions dans le rapport plutôt
opposés au fait qu'il y ait des
structures uniquement pour les enfants à
haut poten
tout simplement et d'ailleurs arielada a
montré à quel point ces enfants
deviennent évidemment des adolescents
puis des adultes vont vivre dans une
société j'ai envie dire ouverte où
chacun doit avoir sa place dans sa
singularité et donc il faut que
l'éducation nationale puisse les
accueillir sans nécessairement faire en
sorte qu'il a des structures qui Leir
soit spécialement dédié euh que ça on y
reviendra tout à l'heure en MO il y a un
débat semble-t-il là-dessus moi ce que
je ce que je crois surtout c'est que il
faut alors en tant que parent moi ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que lorsque j'ai
parceque nous avons appris que notre
enfant était au potentiel a été
diagnostiqué très jeune ça a été
difficile parce que il y avait cette
image effectivement d'Épinal de cet
enfant qui allait être isolé surdoué et
dont on allait pas très bien savoir quoi
faire de son intelligence nous ça nous a
aussi permis de mettre un mot sur tout
simplement des difficultés peut-être de
vie sociale ou ou donc soulagement pour
la mère que vous étiez soulagement et
oui forcément inquiétude
ce que laéé véhicul autour de ses
enfants moi ce que je crois surtout
c'est que ces enfants sont une
formidable richesse comme n'importe quel
enfant dans sa singularité là nous
parlons de ces enfants mais ça vaut pour
d'autres types d'enfants et et et ce
qu'il a apporté en fait à au collectif
est une source pour l'ensemble de la de
la de la classe et nous avons montré
également dans le rapport à quel point
tout ce qui est fait parfois pour ses
enfants alors on parle de George brassin
c'est nous avons visité le DIP collège
George brassin
situé dans le 19e VO et et la structure
qui était dédiée à ces enfants c'est
qu'on voit à quel point ce qui a permis
ce qui qui était fait spécifiquement
pour les enfants bénéficier pour
l'ensemble des enfants par exemple des
cours de philosophie avaient été mis en
place et bien évidemment ces cours de
philosophie était ouvert à l'ensemble
des élèves ça veut dire que les
collégiens de George brassins avaient
accès à des ateliers de philosophie
beaucoup plus jeune que peut-être dans
d'autres dans d'autres collèges tout
cela en fait est un est un un bénéfice
également pour un collectif comme
doivent l'être ces adultes une fois
devenus adultes pour notre société alors
je l'ai dit en introduction de cette
émission il y aurait
200000 enfants concernés aujourd'hui
dans notre pays des études disent aussi
que un/ers seulement de ces élèves
connaissent de réelles difficultés à
l'école autrement dit
euh 70 % des élèves à haut potentiel
intellectuel n'ont pas de problème dans
leur scolarité il faut peut-être nuancer
aussi ce qu'on a vu dans ce film de ce
point de vue alors moi sur ce point je
je je me permettrai une une limite oui
alors d'abord dire qu'effectivement tous
les enfants à haut potentiel Ariel ladad
dit nonont pas nécessairement ne
connaissent pas forcément ni de
difficultés scolaires ni de de
difficultés de relations sociales ça
peut-être rassurer certains qui nous
regard absolument et et et cela cela est
dit régulièrement aujourd'hui par un
certain nombre de psychologues et je
j'approuve cette cette remarque
néanmoins comme il y a une image
d'Épinal qui est celle de l'enfant
surdoué qui serait le petit génie
effectivement vous avez raison de dire
souvent c'est L au notes par exemple
l'identification du au potentiel à
l'école est une difficulté c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous par exemple on
préconiser qu'il y ait une formation
initiale et continue des professeurs
pour qu'ils puissent les identifier
parce que et moi j'en témoigne puisque
dans l'entourage de mon fils il y a un
certain nombre d'enfants qui peuvent
avoir de vraies difficultés scolaires
votre parcours en témoigne aussi et donc
le professeur qui de sa pas ce que c'est
que le haut potentiel va ne va pas
nécessairement se dire que l'élève qui
est face à lui a ses difficultésol cl
parce qu'il est justement au potentiel
vous aviez envie de réagir oui non mais
disons que ce que j'ai trouvé très bien
justement au sein du dispositif de
George brassin c'est que déjà ces
enfantslà sont dans des classes
ordinaires donc déjà je trouve ça et je
trouve voilà que pour l'évolution de de
cette problématique c'est c'est très
positif et justement l'idée de George
brassin c'est de donner les outils à ses
élèves pour qu'il s'intègrent notamment
au sein de leurs camarades et cetera et
ensuite euh poursuivre une scolarité
normale à partir du lycée et aussi je
trouve aussi que c'est avec un espace
dédié on l'a très bien vu dans dans ce
film hein lorsqu'il y a un stress
particulier ce sont des élèves qui
peuvent aller dans cet espace dédié euh
avec un tuteur oui et puis ça évite
également justement de coller une
étiquette sur l'enfant comme quoi voilà
il aurait une différence non il a tout à
fait les atouts pour s'intégrer au sein
de ses camarade en revanche il y a
peut-être une une manière de
l'accompagner euh tout au long de sa
scolarité qui lui permettra ensuite
d'exprimer son potentiel et de faire
aussi bénéficier au groupe quelque part
alors parce qu'il y a une question aussi
centrale qui est posée par par ce film
euh faut-il des des structures dédiées
vous avez commencé à y répondre et nous
donner votre avis sur le sujet faut-il
des classes dédiées des structures
dédiées euh ou faut-il
euh résolument prendre une démarche
d'inclusion et de garder ses élèves
coûte que coûte dans le le cursus
scolaire classique vous avez un avis sur
le sujet oui
je pense que George brassin les
professeurs sont sensibilisés il faut
que les professeurs tous de primaire de
secondaire soient sensibiliser au dons
intellectuel qui puisse le détecter je
vois des enfants ils ont passé une année
magnifique parce que le professeur était
sensibilisé avait lui-même des enfants
doués devait l'être aussi comprenait
bien cet enfant c'était idylique l'année
d'après c'était quelqu'un qui trouvait
que Ctait un élève perturbateur qui
posait des questions idiotes et hop ça
tombe ça dégringole c'est et c'est ça
devient une catastrophe et comme ces
enfants sont hyp
sensibles pour eux c'est la la fin du
monde le professeur les aime pas ils
sont nul et c'est la fin du monde ils
sont aussi sensibles qu'ils sont
intelligents c'est une des spécificités
de ces personnes oui oui alors
maintenant on parle de potentiel
émotionnel ou quelque chose mais c'est
un peu un peu surfait parce que ça se
mesure pas mais ils ont une sensibilité
parce que ils perçoivent les émotions
des gens les sentiments des gens ils
perçoivent l'agressivité même si' voit
quelqu'un tout sourire mais que la
personne derrière est un peu agressive
ou méchante ils le perçoivent ils
réagissent très très fort et les parents
que vous rencontrez quelle est leur
réaction après le résultat d'un test qui
prouve qu'effectivement le caution
intellectuel est supérieur à 130 hein
puisque c'est la est-ce qu'ils veulent
que leur enfant aill dans des
établissements spécifiques est-ce qu'il
vous posent la question euh des des
classes spécifiques il en existe très
peu en France he c'est peut-être une
question que je voudrais vous poser
qu'est-ce que vous préconisez dans il y
a pas de réponse il faut faire avec ce
que ce qu'il y a sur place oui donc il
faut être pratique s'il y a une école où
ils sont sensibilisés il faut que
l'école soit sensibilisée sans être
vraiment dédié aux enfants doués il y
avait une école avec la directrice on
s'entendait très bien je de si je
préconisais un saut de classe elle était
d'accord si je mettais certaines choses
en place elle était d'accord et puis
elle a été virée par l'équipe et c'était
la catastrophe après c'était la
catastrophe et et j'ai vu il y a pas
très longtemps une elle était pas petite
elle avait 14 ans elle avait été
harcelée parce que maintenant on parle
du harcèlement alors c'est pas les
rouquins qui sont harcelés hein c'est
les enfants doués euh oui oui oui mais
on l'a vu dans ce documentaire
d'ailleurs vous pouvez en témoigner hein
il y a une forme de harcèlement
scolaireoui c'est les enfants cette
différence cette par pas défendre et
puis ils comprennent pas eux ils sont
gentils un enfant doué est gentil donc
ils comprennent pas qu'on puisse être
méchant donc ils se mettent dans
l'esprit mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
pour qu'il soit méchant j'ai dû faire
quelque chose ils sont fondamentalement
gentils un enfant doué à moins d'être
complètement pervers il est il est
vraiment gentil j'ai vu donc cette jeune
fille puis qu'elle avait 14 ans
adolescente et bien elle avait été
harcelée au primaire et là elle est dans
une dans son école il y a des classes
spécialisées et quand elle a parlé du
harcèlement mais elle avait 9 ans 10 ans
elle s'est mise à pleurer à la 14 ans et
elle s'est encore mise à pleurer en en
parlant c'est dire à quel point ça
l'avait traumatisé et là elle est dans
une classe au sein de la même de cette
école hein c'est en blieu parisienne et
là dans une classe et là elle respire
elle est elle est quel est l'état des
lieux dans au sein de l'éducation
nationale telle que vous l'avez constaté
pour ce rapport concernant les
établissements qui tentent des
expériences justement de classe
spécifiqu de dispositifs spécifiques
pour pour ses élèves et les autres il y
a un état des lieux on a l'impression
qu'il y a finalement très peu
d'établissements qui se préoccupent
réellement spécifique de ces de ces
élèves et que la tendance est plutôt
d'essayer de les les maintenir dans le
cursus scolaire classique alors je dois
dire d'abord si vous me le permettez que
dans le cadre de ce rapport qui parfois
a été discuté par certains acteurs que
d'abord il a été le fruit de nombreuses
auditions de manière Ariel l a fait
partie des personnal abumement mais il y
avait également des des
neurologues il y avait des
professionnels de
santé il y avait évidemment des
associations de parents mais il y avait
une multitude d' d' acteurs partie
prenante et en fait ce qui revient de la
part à peu près de de tout le monde de
tous les acteurs c'est que un enfant un
adolescent qui a haut potentiel c'est un
être qui va vous bousculer il va vous
bousculer dans ses certitudes dans vos
certitude il va vous remettre en
question il va tout le temps vous
demander le pourquoi du comment donc
c'est d'abord ça peut être l sent ça
peut être pénible ça peut déranger une
classe et donc parce qu'il va bousculer
l'enseignant he au premier chef he
ander référ la conissance profess il a
Rapp à latice l'injustice qui est
particulier tout ça ce sont des points
communs liés au aux enfants ha potentiel
et donc il faut en effet que les
professeurs ai été sensibilisés à ce
sujet là pour comprendre ce que ce qui
effectivement le cas des professeurs de
George brassin un autre dispositif à
Paris à Jean où les les profess
16 et et la vertu de C de ces établis
c'est ce que nous on souhaite à
l'échelle du territoire national c'est
qu'il y a une sensibilité au moins d'un
professeur dans l'équipe pédagogique de
l'élève qui lui va être un relais alors
auprès des autres professeurs d'abord va
être présent évidemment au m du conseil
de classe parce qu'il y a des élèves
pour lesqueles ça peut être nécessaire
il y a des moments au cours de la vie
disons que l'adolescence c'est pas
forcément le moment le plus serein pour
les parents et à foruie lorsque vous
êtes parent d'un enfant à haut potentiel
donc ça peut être nécessaire et par
ailleurs effec nous plaidons aussi pour
que dans l'ensemble des collèges il y
ait des dispositifs donc qui sont
appelés diep que l'on a vu dans le dans
le dans le documentaire et qui
permettent à ces élèves de pouvoir avoir
un salle de décompression on peut
l'appeler un peu comme ça euh à à George
brassin mais je crois que c'était le cas
mais
à ganson de sa c'est le cas le ZEP est
ouvert aux autres élèves il n'est pas
uniquement réservé aux enfants à haut
potentiel on peut avoir des copains
voyez ce qui m'a posé problème en
regardant ce film c'est c'estàdire qu'on
George brassin ce collège qu'on a vu
vous on a cité quelques établissements
mais au final il y a très peu
d'établissementè Frédéric Monier qui est
député de cor absolument qui est député
de coris rappelez à quel point dans la
ruralité il y a encore plus de
difficulté parce que en zone urbaine ou
périurbaine on est en lien quand même
avec des professionnels qui peuvent nous
nous nous orienter mais en zone urbaine
rural c'est particulièrement difficile
pour les familles de de de d'être
d'avoir des solutions
alors par rapport à cette solution ce
que j'ai trouvé formidable et puis
notamment dans votre rapport que j'avais
parce que j'avais lu en partie votre
rapport et donc oui c'est ce qui est
formidable c'est que aujourd'hui
l'enseignement public se préoccupe de
cette question donc c'est ce que j'ai
observé à George brassins effectivement
les professeurs sont formé en
revanche justement bah c'est peut-être
une
opportunou ils sont formés effectivement
et ce que enfin est-ce qu'ils sont
formés dans les milieux rurx dont on a
parlé c'est pas de savoir aussi si
justement en rapport avec ce que vous
avez observé euh quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai que les
parents d'élèves m'ont interpellé
plusieurs fois pour me dire que tous les
ans il est question que le dieep
justement au sein de George au sein de
George brassins
et est remis en question notamment pour
des questions de financement alors je
connais pas profondément la la nature on
va dire du du problème financier mais
est-ce que Madame rixin est-ce que dans
votre rapport et au fur à mesure des
auditions que vous avez passé alors le
JEP he ça a été cité au moins deux fois
on va rappeler hein c'est un dispositif
d'intégration pour les élèves à haut
potentiel alors ces deux dispositifs
donc parisiens il faut le dire qu' que
nous n'avons pas vu ailleurs sur le
territoire en tout cas le ministère nous
en a pas fait remonter de de
d'équivalent ont pu être mis en place
notamment des des financements grâce à
des financements européens à la base ils
ont ensuite été prolongés grâce à à à
l'investissement de l'éducation
nationale nous nous plaidons vous l'avez
compris dans le rapport non seulement
pour qu'il soit maintenu dans ces
établissements mais qu' soit également
démultiplié sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais si vous me permettez également de
rajer il y a l'éducation national mais
il y a également des collectivités
locales qui font des choses et je me
permettrai moi de citer les sones qui
régulièrement le Conseil départemental
organise des colloques ouverts donc à
l'ensemble des membres de l'éducation
nationale
euh avec une sensibilité qui peuvent
parfois durer une journée entière sur la
question du haut potentiel et donc il y
a effectivement ce que fait l'éducation
nationale il y a ce que les
collectivités locales et et puis parfois
il faut bien le dire c'est à
l'initiative d'un élève dans l'école que
les habitudes sont un peu bousculées
lors de la manière quand on accueille un
enfant parfois en situation de handicap
voilà il faut généraliser les bonnes
pratiques c'est ce que vous disiez dans
dans dans ce rapport en citant notamment
les établissements dont on a parlé à
l'instant on va voir un extrait du film
si vous êtes d'accord je vous donne la
parole juste après c'est un élève qui se
dit vraiment soulagé d'avoir pu sauter
une classe
je je n'étais pas bah épanoui ça c'est
une évidence avec mes camarades qui
franchement ne me confortaiit pas dans
l'idée que j'avais ma place dans dans
ces classes et donc madame S Michel a
décidé en tant que principale de me
faire sauter une classe alors c'était
une
décision voilà qui a é un poids ça fait
un reménage enfin je te laisse imaginer
tous les mais ça c'est fait ça c'est
fait son choix c'était pas de me faire
sauter une classe pour Mo mon plaisir
pas du tout elle m'a dit Enzo moi je
suis convaincu d'une chose c'est que
vous serez plus vite vous sortirez du
système scolaire et plus vite vous serez
épanoui parce que vous pourrez faire ce
que vous
souhaitez alors ce saute là c'est
visiblement ça lui a sauvé la vie avec
une belle rencontre he visiblement avec
un enseignant par ailleurs le saut de
class souvent une solution mise en avant
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez solu c'est
la
solution de secours il ne faut pas
hésiter en primaire parce que c'est très
très lent le les apprentissages sont
très lents sont très répé en particulier
le le CE2 et c'est la classe que
l'éducation nationale accepte à peu près
de sauter parce que c'est une répétition
du CE1 le CE2 c'est il faut sauter une
classe après je leur dis mais ne te
plains pas je t'ai fait gagner une année
de scolarité et alors ça c'est c'est
très jeune hein c'est de oui mais en si
on est decté un peu plus tard hein ce
qui est regrettable he si j'ai bien
suivi ce que vous avez dit en début de
l'émission on peut saiter une classe au
lycée par exemple au lycée non ça va
vite
au au collège alors évidemment il y a
des écoles où on fait le collège on fait
4 6e 5e en une année ce que je voulais
dire c'est queun fois j'avais fait
euh une conférence pour l'éducation
nationale sur les enfants doués donc il
y avait beaucoup de professeurs mais
après il s'est avéré qu'ils étaient tous
parents d'enfants doués donc il venait
pas du tout au titre de professeur il
venait au titre de parents si bien que
effectivement ils sont ouverts ils sont
ils comprennent mais il faut être
sensibilisé et c'est pas en faisant une
journée comme ça au sein de quantités de
formation que les que les professeurs
seront sensibilisés c'est c'est en
profondeur c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça il c'est tout juste ils
n'apprennent pas que ça n'existe pas et
que c'est les parents qui s'imaginent et
cetera alors peut-être pour aller dans
votre sens autre piste évoqué dans votre
rapport c'est le tutorat alors ce sont
peut-être ces ces professeurs S
siensibilisé qui doivent être les
tuteurs où est-ce qu'on en est sur le
tutor une aide individuelle un coup de
main un coup de pouce un accompagnement
individuel de la part de tuteur et qui
seraient ces tuteurs donc nous avons
dans la à la suite de ce rapport avec
Frédéric meunier fait adopter donc dans
le projet de loi qui a suivi l'adoption
du rapport le texte de Jean-Michel
Blanquer le fait que d'abord on
reconnaisse le potentiel dans la loi
donc aujourd'hui le haut potentiel
intellectuel est reconnu dans la loi et
ensuite nous avons notamment demander à
ce qu'il y ait cette formation initiale
donc des professeurs et ça me semble
d'autant plus important qu'il y ait
voyez une première sensibilisation
c'est-à-dire une
perméabilité à reconnaître à à à ce à ce
sujet-l ce qui permet ensuite de
maintenir une formation une attention et
en effet il y a un intérêt de la part de
certains professeurs à ce sujet qui vont
donc être aller plus en en profondeur
dans leur formation soit parce qu'ils
sont concernés direct exement soit parce
que ils ont un intérêt pour le sujet et
ils vont devenir effectivement des
tuteurs ou des référents pour l'équipe
pédagogique et vous savez il suffit
enfin moi je l'ai vu après on a vu
également on était dans de nombreux
établissements il suffit qu'à l'échelle
d'un établissement déjà il y ait un ou
deux professeurs qui soient sensibilisés
au sujet et on gagne beaucoup parce
qu'il ils vont en effet former leurs
collègues et permettre d'avoir une
écoute un lien entre les familles les
élèves et l'équipe pédagogique et si je
m'adresse à la mère maintenant votre
fils lui aussi à un moment ou un autre a
fait ses rencontres a eu la chance
d'avoir un tuteur donc moi mon fils a eu
la chance de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
dieep donc AG Ganon de saillli ouais et
et aujourd'hui il est en seconde et il
regrette encore le dieep et les
rencontres qu'il a pu y faire et ça a
permis effectivement de déminer un
certain nombre de situations notamment
au moment de l'adolescence parce comme
le disait ada et je crois que c'est un
message qu'il faut faire passer c'est
que la grosse difficulté des enfants au
potentiel c'est leur rencontre avec
l'effort l'effort scolaire intellectuel
qu'ils ne connaissent pas et à un moment
donné ouis il y a bien un moment dans la
scolarité l'effort intellectuel
l'organisation en seconde c'est en
seconde oui ouais il y a 2,3 % de la
population française
euh qui présenterait un haut potentiel
intellectuel ça représente tout de même
1,5 millions de personnes un peu plus
vous êtes aujourd'hui documentariste
réalisateur
euh vous êtes épanoui vous avez eu un
parcours épanoui après votre scolarité
qui on l'a bien compris avait été
chaotique difficile douloureuse il y a
un après et un après optimiste écoutez
c'est vrai que le jour où j'ai commencé
on va dire à travailler par intérêt
disons pour quelque chose qui
m'intéressait réellement je me suis
pleinement consacré effectivement à
voilà à ce à ce métier où effectivement
je j'ai trouvé ma voix donc c'est une
chance mais disons que c'est vrai que
c'est au prix quand même d'un parcours
assez compliqué que je ne vais pas non
plus développer et peut-être aussi des
des conséquences aussi sur euh comment
dire sur des réactions que je peux avoir
aujourd'hui bien sûr parce que le le
vécu psychosocial quoi qu'il arrive il y
a un impact euh sur notre bien-être une
fois adulte aussi et donc c'est pour ça
que je trouve indispensable que le que
les établissements publics prennent en
compte cette questionlà et aussi je
trouve aussi important que ce de
sensibiliser également les les quartiers
populaires puisque les je il y
a malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est une
majorité d'établissements privés qui
accueill qui sont en capacité
d'accueillir ses enfants là pour la
prise en charge et donc c'est pour ça
que j'encourage vivement l'éducation
nationale à se préoccuper de cette
question et malheureusement et bien on
le le le dispositif de George brassins
et menacé alors que c'est un des tout
premiers à être mis en place et et c'est
très et puis il y a un symbole important
aussi c'est qu' se trouve dans le 19e
arrondissement de Paris donc et c'est
d'ailleurs au fur à mesure que j'ai fait
ce documentaire je me suis aperçu plus
que jamais que l'ensemble des couches
sociales sont concerné par cette
question là
ça absolument alors moi simplement sur
laprè et vous allez vous partager une
minute ça sera la conclusion de cette
émission non non je voudrais savoir
après après après la scolarité après la
scolarité quand les gens trouent
intellectuelle est-ce qu'elle continue à
avoir des difficultés par
rapportand quand ils trouvent leur voix
c'est magnifique justement quand c'est
la c'est personnel ils donnent leur
pleine mesure il y a pas de au contraire
c'est c'est magnifique c'est grâce à au
gens doué que la société avance ils
apportent quelque chose à la société et
puis même et c'est là que leur
potentialité peut s'exprimer chercheurs
les médecins enfin tous ceux qui les
artistes tous ces gens-là sont doués ils
apportent quelque chose mais ceux qui
n'ont pas été identifi qui se retrouve à
travailler dans un bureau sous-employé
avec des chefs qui sont moins
intelligents que lui c'est dramatique là
il y a un problème je voulais juste dire
une chose il y a quand même le rôle des
associations locales qui organisent des
colloques des conférences très souvent
il m'inviter je m'inviter parce que
avant le covid après non et quand même
les associations locales font des choses
juste dans leur région comme ça il y a
quand même ce rôle là qu'il faut pas
négliger bon ben on les salue au passage
merci vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à à cette émission autour de
votre film euh la dur vie des surdoué
qu'on a découvert à l'occasion de cette
émission debatdoc vos réactions et
j'imagine qu'elles seront nombreuses ça
sera sur
hashtagdbadoc nos invités pourront
d'ailleurs évidemment bien évidemment
réagir à ce que seront ses réactions à
cette émission merci à selmaali qui
comme elle accoutumé m'a aidé à préparer
cette émission je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débadoc et ça sera bien entendu avec son
documentaire et son débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt